ah
[Música]
i
esta semana desde viena representantes
de los gobiernos de eeuu e irán se
reúnen para intercambiar ideas sobre
cómo restaurar el acuerdo nuclear
firmado entre las dos partes en el 2015
y terminado unilateralmente por trump
hace tres años todavía no están
confirmadas reuniones oficiales entre
las partes y la comunicación sería
indirecta además de reducir la
producción del material nuclear y
permitir acceso de inspectores
internacionales a sus plantas de
producción nuclear el secretario de
estado- anthony blinken dijo que este
acuerdo tiene que ser más fuerte más
extenso sugiriendo que tiene que ir más
allá del 2030 como estaba planeado
inicialmente sería un acuerdo además que
incluya restricciones a las capacidades
de irán sobre sus misiles y sobre el
apoyo que le da a grupos terroristas y
la ayuda del gobierno en síria
negociaciones que pueden tomar meses o
años
[Música]
cuando se lee en la prensa o se ve la
televisión y miran se pueden ver dos
posiciones muy concretas una la que
apoya el regreso al acuerdo nuclear y al
levantamiento de las sanciones que es el
sector moderado y reformista y aquellos
que se niegan incluso a ese regreso al
acuerdo nuclear que serían los más
radicales sin embargo desde lo alto del
nissan del sistema parece haber un
acuerdo para que se reactiven de acuerdo
si eeuu decide levantar esas sanciones
económicas que impuso el presidente de
donald trump en el 2018 que le han hecho
un gran daño al país especialmente con
el agravante de la pandemia en el último
año para entender la posición de los
radicales hay que mirar también las
elecciones que vendrán en el próximo
junio que ellos quieren ganar y no
quieren que el sector moderado y
reformista sea quien diga que el acuerdo
nuclear se reactivó durante su gobierno
[Música]
el acuerdo nuclear con irán se ha
convertido en uno de los grandes
objetivos de la unión europea que actúa
como coordinador a la llegada de joe
biden a la casa blanca se ha convertido
en una nueva esperanza para que este
país vuelva a incorporarse a este pacto
las próximas negociaciones van a abordar
sobre cómo levantar las sanciones a irán
pero también de que este país cumpla con
sus compromisos algo que no ha hecho en
los últimos meses pero también el papel
de eeuu a partir de ahora justo en este
mes de abril se cumplen seis años de que
se firmara este histórico acuerdo para
la unión europea es un gran hito de la
diplomacia internacional y quiere luchar
hasta el final para que se cumplan todos
los compromisos a pesar de las presiones
internacionales la unión europea insiste
en que gracias al acuerdo el mundo es un
lugar mucho más seguro con este pacto
que si no estuviera
[Música]